[müzik]
Evet ABS'nin gülüş. Hadi
bismillahirrahmanirrahim. Şimdi geldik
neye? Orta Çağ'da Avrupa'ya. Ama bu ders
biraz +1 bak haberin olsun farklı
şeylerden bahsedereceğim sana. Hah.
Şimdi arkana yaslan. Listen to me. Çok
very carefully. Şimdi Orta Çağ'da Avrupa
biraz erdemim benim be. Su gibin aziz
ol. Allah senden razı olsun koçum benim.
Yemin ediyorum var ya yukarıdan koştur
koştur in gel hemen.
Bismillahirrahmanirrahimade gir
anlatmaya başla. Gel zomzomla beni
şokamaya geldim. Şimdi Orta Çağ'da
Avrupa'yı neyle başlatacağız? Kavimler
göçüsüyle başlatacağız. Hah. Şimdi İslam
öncesi Türk tarihinde anlatıyoruz ya biz
kavimler göçüsünü. Kavimler bizim Orta
Asya'daki kavimler. Rahat mı battı
dersin Çin baskısı? Moğol baskısı. Ne
bilen ne baskısı? Aman gökyüzünün olduğu
her yerde bizimdir anlayışı var mı? Var
değil mi? Tebili mekanda pararlık vardır
dedik. Bizimkiner ortasında orta
kameraya gel. Bizimkiner orta kameraya
gel. Gel orta kameraya. Orta kamera
geçir beni. Hah tamam. Bizimkinler Orta
Asya'nın ortasından bir çıktılar
buradan. Yürü babam yürü yürü yürü yürü
yürü yürü yürü yürü. Bir geldik
şuralarda Hazar Denizi var. Hazar
Denizi'nin etrafında barbar kavimler
yaşar. Kim onlar? Angle, Burgon, Frank,
Sakson, Ostrogotlar, Vizigotlar vesaire
kuşatlar, öbür gotlar, bu kotlar. Bunlar
bir baktılar anam Türkler geliyor.
Türkler geliyor. Türkler ya lele ya
lele. La adamın bilinçaltında ne var?
Türk geliyor değil mi? Bunlar kaçmaya
başladı. Bu kavimler birbirini ite kaka
ite kaka. Bizimki nerede? Yürüyoruz biz
de. Tamam mı? Bir baktık önümüzde bir
toz bulutu var. Önde barbar kavimler.
Arkada biz Türkler. Kavimler
birbirlerini ite kaka, ite kaka te
nereden? Nereye kadar? Avrupa'nın içine
kadar geldiler. İşte bu birinci Avrasya
maratonuna ÖSYM ne diyor? Kavimler göçü
diyor. Değil mi? Kavimlerin göçüyle
bunlar daldılar Avrupa'nın içine. Kim
güçlüyse onun ayakta kaldığı bir ortam
da ortaya çıktı mı? E çıktı. Yani kim
güçlüyse o ayakta kalır. Ortada ne? Roma
İmparatorluğu kaldı. Kabak gibi ikiye
bölündü. Doğu Roma, Batı Roma diye değil
mi? Herkes yıkıldı gitti. önce barbar
kavimler arkasından biz Türkler bir
girdik tam bir ne ortamı var tam bir
kaos ortamı var şimdi burada bizi
ilgilendiren yerlerden bahsedeceğiz gel
zomzom kamerasına gelti
ayakta kalan tek bir kurum var lan koca
Roma İmparatorluğu bölündü gitti la
ortada ne kral kaldı ne imparator kaldı
ama ayakta kalan bir tane kurum var kim
o kilise ve papalık lı nasıl ayakta
kaldı ha gelenlerin bir kısmısı
Hristiyanlığı kabul etti Bir de bu
papaın yetkileri var. Ne la o yetkiler?
Arkan Ayaslan listumu çok veri karı
fili. Bak şimdi abiciğim bu papa.
Neyse çok şeyine girmeyeceğim yani hani
kapattırmayalım kanalı değil mi? Bu
papaın yetkileri var. Ne onlar mesela
vaftiz. Bak hepinizin duyduğu ama
bilmediği şeyi anlat verim. Baptisz
dediğiniz olay şudur. Hristiyanlık
inancında doğduğunda annen karnından
bütün günahlarınla beraber doğarmışsın.
Ama bizim İslam inancı nasıl? Bebek
doğduğu zaman günahsızdır, ispettir
değil mi? Günahsızdır değil mi? Böyle
yuz değil mi? Onlara göre bütün
günahlarıyla beraber doğarmışsın. Ve
papanın suyuyla yıkanıp kutsanıp vaftiz
edildiğinde hoppa günahlarından
arındığına inanır mısın? Yani Papa öyle
bir sistem kurmuş ki doğduğun andan
itibaren kime muhtaçsın? Papayya, Rahibe
din adamına muhtaçsın. Onunla ne olman
lazım? Vaftiz olman lazım. Değil mi?
İşte bu inanış onlara öyle bir devam
ediyor ki şimdi doğdun papaın suyuyla
yıkandın. E papaın suyunun üstüne su
olur mu? Olmaz. Bir daha adamlar
yıkanmıyor. Kurban olduğunum. Orta çağ
işte böyle pislik, hastalık bilmem neyin
olduğu bir şeye dönüşüyor. Adamlar
yıkanmıyor. Niye? Papaya olan
bağlılıklarını gösteriyor. Bir kere
papanın suyuyla vapildin sana vapildiğin
suyu da veriyor. Sabah kalkıyorsun şöyle
kenara doğru atıyorsun. Elini yüzünü
yıkıyorsun puf deyip tükürüyorsun.
Ertesi gün gene aynı su. Başka suyla
işin gücün yok. Değil mi? İşte bununla
alakalı o bütün hastalıklar, pislikler
hep nereden çıktı? E buralardan çıktı
işte. Yok ki tuvalet kültürü yok. Yemek
kültürü yok. Ev kültürü yok. Ortaç
Avrupa hakikaten de rezil kepaza
karanlık bir ne? Karanlık bir dönem
değil mi? Adam mesela şurada yemeğini
yiyor. Ev şurası olsun tamam mı? Orada
şurada yemeğini yiyor. Şurada yatıyor.
Şurada kişini tasa yapıyor. Hop atıyor
aşağıya. A yukarıdan aşağı sallıyor. E
sen şimdi sanıyorsun ki topukla ayakkabı
niye çıktı? Niye çıktı? Ha modern olsun
göyümüz olsun falan değil abim. Yerleri
götürüyor lan. Kurban olduğum
basmayalım diye. Şemsiye niye çıktı?
Tamam. Sevgilinle buluşacaksın. E ne
güzel. Oh. Giyindik böyle göbekten
bilmem neli kıstırmalı korseli bilmem
neli giydin. Fittiri [kahkaha] fittiri
fittiri fittiri giderken yukarıdan
birisi löp diye attı. E ne olacak? E
şemsiye yağmurdan kurulalım diyor ki
kafamıza pok düşmesin diye. O parfüm
niye çıktı? Kurban olduğum ne dersin?
Niye lan? Adam o kadar pis kokuyor ki
artık kendi kokusundan kendisi rahatsız
olmuş. Senin o medeniyet diye
gördüklerinin çoğu pislikten dolayı
çıkıyor ya. Hatta Avrupa'da var bir
kral. Tamam. Avrupa'da var bir kral.
Doğduğunda Papa tarafından vaftiz
edilmiş. Suyuzu görmüş. Bir daha 40
yaşın, 50 yaşına kadar adam su yüzü
görmemiş. E ilerleyen süreçte
hastalanıyor. Tamam. Avrupalı doktorlar
geliyor bakıyorlar çözüm yok. Tamam.
Diyorlar ki İslam dünyasından birine
çağıralım. Doktor çağıralım. Nereden
çağıralım? İspanya'da yok mu Endülüs
Emevileri? Tamam mı? Oradan bir tane
doktor çağıralım dediler. Oh. Hayırlı
uğurlu olsun. Hemen ulak geldi İslam
dünyasından doktora dedi ki ya böyle
böyle bizim kralımız dedi hasta dedi bir
gel bak falan deyince tamam dedi. Siz
gidin ben de geliyorum ardınızdan dedi.
Adam Avrupa'ya girdi. Lan
bu ne lan? Lef gibi kokuyor. Orada bir
tane çoban görüyor. Diyor ki lan çoban
diyor bu koku ne diyor. Çoban diyor ki
hangi koku? Adam alışmış abim. Yani hani
o kokuya diyor ki Allah belanızı versin.
Geçimi kemirdiniz naylon mu yuttunuz? Ne
ettiniz Allah belanızı vere deyip tamam
mı? krala doğru yaklaştıkça ve adam da
diyor ki ya diyor ki işte çoban diyor
ben diyor sizin kralınızı arıyorum
deyince çoban diyor ki yah diyor bizim
kral diyor mübarek adam diyor tam diyor
912 metre diyor ne doğrusu 912 metreden
herifin kokusu duyuluyormuş bak o var ya
o papaya bağlılık mübareklik gibi
anlaşılıyor tamam ve eee bizim bak diyor
şu kokuyu aldın mı diyor hani diyor küf
mantar diyor paslandırda diyor şey çıkar
kokusu var ya diyor bozuk yumurta kokusu
diyor ha o kokuyu diyor takip et diyor
917 metre sonra diyor sağda diyor
gelirken solda da diyor. Tamam bizim
ilerledikçe doktorla kokunun şiddet şey
artıyor. Böyle durd falan derken kralın
sarayının önüne geldiğinde orada
bayılıyor kokudan artık. Tamam. Hemen
bunu yakaça çıkarıyorlar kralın
huzuruna. Bu burnu dıkalı yah diyor seni
diyor böyle muayene edemem. Senin bir
diyor soyunup diyor senin diyor bir
yıkanman lazım deyince hasta yatağından
kakıver diyen kral bir melun bir
Müslüman doktor bile bana bak benim bu
zamana kadar biriktirdiğim mübarekliğimi
papaya olan bağlılığımı ben bir Müslüman
doktora verir miyim lan ölürüm de
yıkanmam diyor. Tamam bunun üstüne bizim
İslam aleminin doktoru da ulan diyor
bana tobun para mı saydım geber lan bana
ne deyip hemen bıp pır kaçıyor. Tamam
kaçıyor gidiyor İspanya'dan kendini
Akdeniz'e değil Atlas Okyanusuna atacak.
Orada yıkansa anca arınır değil mi? Tam
atlasın sona bir buç toplu saltoyla tam
böyle girecekken arkadan kralın adamları
bunu yakaladıklarıyla çekiyorlar geriye.
Niye? E kralın can tatlı. Alın gelin o
doktoru baksın bana. Bu benden ölüyorum
ben diye. Tamam gidiyorlar diyor ki
böyle olmaz. Benim seni diyor önce bir
diyor temizlemem lazım tamam adamın
üstündekileri çıkaracaklar. Çıkarmak ne
mümkün? Elbise kendiyle beraber büyümüş
gitmiş değil mi? Üsttekini yırta kanat
ayakkabı almış. Turbası ayakkabıda
kendiyle beraber büyümüş gitmiş ve
üstündekiler atıp böyle yırta kanata
falan çıkarıyorlar. Yapışmış. Sadece
bellar iniyor kalkıyor. Bu kadar
hacetine giderken e artık sen düşün
sarkıtlar, dikitler bilmem neleri. Anam
bizim İslam aleminin doktoru o şeyi
kralı 7 gün 7 gece yedi kazan suyla
yüyüp yıkayıp sabunlayıp keselemiş.
Yümüş yıkamış keselemiş değil mi? En son
ortaya kral gibi bir tane daha kral
çıkıyor. Neyden? Kirden böyle kral
yıkanıp rahatladıktan sonra hamamdan
sonra oh bir de güzel bir Türk kahvesi
böyle bizim Isparta gül lokumuyla
beraber verdiğle kral kahve içip gül
lokumunu attıyla oh be demiş bütün
hastalık bitti her fası değil ki pis
yani. Tamam. Sonra kral hamamdan bu
sefer çıktığımda
bu ne? Geçimi gemirdiniz bu ne koku dedi
diyor. Önceden en çok kendi kokuyordu.
Farkında bile değildi. Anladın mı ya?
mesele. Şimdi o kral bir tane şey
yapıyor. Kanun yapıyor. Diyor ki, "Benim
ülkemde herkes bundan sonra yılda bir
kere mecburi zorunlu yıkanacak" diyor
ya. Daha o zamana kadar yok abim Orta
Çağ Avrupa'sı vallaha pis ya. Pis. İşte
bu papa var ya papa adamı dinden imandan
atar değil mi? İşte aparoz da odur. Bak
vaftiz papaın suyuyla yıkanma kutsanma
doğduğun anda değil mi? Aparoz ise
papaın kişiyi dinden atmasıdır. Şimdi
papa gözünün kesmediği adamı kovdum lan
seni defol deyip sanki babasının
diniymiş gibi adam dindarlığı yapıyor
atıyor. Ulan ben ne anladım bu işten? E
aklına yattı mı? Ezberleme. Neyi anla?
Mantığı anla. Papa'nın müthiş bir neyi
var? Sosyal etkisi var değil mi?
Arkasından enterdi dediğiniz olay. Şimdi
artık Papa o kadar güçleniyor ki, siyasi
tor o kadar zayıflamış, güç kaybetmiş ki
Papa'nın elinden taç giymek bir neye
dönmüş? Ayrıcalığa dönmüş. Enterdi ise
o. Tamam. Sonra Papa krala taç
giydirmeye başlıyor. Papa'nın elinden
taç giymeyen krala halk biat etmiyor. E
zamanla papa enterdiyle krala taç
giydirdiği gibi o tacı da alabilir mi?
alabilir. Ya kurban olduğum Papa'nın
yetkilere baksana ya. Papa siyasi
yetkiyi, gücü eline alıyor. Şimdi
baktığın zaman vaftiz kutsanma. Doğru
mu? Kutsama dediğin olay. Sosyal olarak
doğduğun anda kime muhtaçsın? Papayya
muhtaçsın. Aparos dinden atma. E dinden
atma da sosyal gücü var mı? Var. Arıza
çıkarabilir misin? Çıkaramazsın. Enterdi
krala ne giydiriyor? taç giydiriyor.
Giydirdiği gibi o tacı geri de alabilir
mi? Geri de alabilir. Bak Papa'nın
siyasi yetkileri de oluşmaya başlıyor.
Anlaştık. Endüljans ise, endüljans ise
ha bizim o kral ne oldu biliyor musun?
Enterdi oldu. Niye? Papa tacını aldı. Ne
demek lan yıkanmak? Ben siz
yıkamayacayacağınız demedim mi lan? Ne
geliyor? Al papa komple hepsini top
komple dinden atıyor. Siyasi, hukuki,
adli, madli, seksi, dini, ilmi, bilmi,
filmi her türlü güç kimin elinde?
Kilisenin, papalığın elinde. Endüljans
ise Hristiyanlığın özünde olan bir şey.
Ne o? Hac ibadetidir. Bak abim, İslam
dünyasında da, Hristiyan dünyasında da
hac ibadeti var mı? Var. Biz hacca niye
gideriz? Günahlarımızdan arınmaya
gideriz. Değil mi? Bir gün Avrupa'da şey
zengin adamlardan birisi James Bot
çantasına doldurmuş paraları altınları.
Tamam mı? Geliyor. "Papacığım" diyor.
"Ben" diyor "Hacca gidiyorum" diyor.
"Gideyim." Onlar nereye gidiyorlar?
Hacca. E Kudüs'e, Kudüs'e gelecekler.
Tamam mı? Avrupa'nın ortasından ben
diyor Kudüs'e gideceğim. Hac edeceğim.
Orada diyor günahlarımdan arınacağım.
Haz İsa'nın evinde şey yapacağım.
Havareleri falan deyip hadi bana müsa
seviyorum seni dediğinde paba diyor ki
dur lan diyor. Nereye gidiyorsun? Diyor.
O yanındaki ne diyor? Açıyor bir çuval
para. O anam anam diyor. Papa diyor ki
gel lan buraya diyor. Oğlum diyor yolda
diyor Müslümanlar var. O Müslümanlar
barbar seni yer yuvalar yutar öldürürler
lan seni diyor. Sen gel diyor. Sen hacca
niye gidiyorsun? günahlarından arınmaya.
"Oğlum benim yukarıdakiyle aramıyor. Ben
ona söylerim. Senin günahlarını affeder
lan" diyor. Eee ne gerek var gitmeye?
Sen ağırlığı bıraksan, emaneti bıraks
söylerim senin günahlarını affeder
diyor. Vallahi mı papacığım? Hakikaten
papacığım işte papa insanları böyle
salaklaştırmış. Bu hac ibadeti ilerleyen
süreçte neye döndü? Günah çıkarmaya
döndü. Papa artık tarife oluşturmuş.
Küçük günah 50 kuruş, büyük günah 100
kuruş falan diye toplu tenzilatı 75
kuruşa. Ya bu düşün kurban olduğumun ya
böyle günah tarifesi falan çıkarmış.
Mesela geldin papacığım ben çok
günahkarım ama param yok. Nasıl
yapacağız? İşte nasıl yapacağınızı anla
yani hani buna dönmüş al herif neye
döndürdü bunu? Günah çıkarmaya döndürdü.
Kimisi para verdi, kimisi arsasını
verdi, kimi bilmem neyini verdi. Artık
Papa siyasi, sosyal, ekonomik olarak
güçleri eline aldı mı? E aldı. Anlaştık.
Sonra Papa dedi ki, "Ulen" dedi, "bir
gün topladı hepsini. Gelin" dedi,
"toplanıyoruz. Yarın dedi büyük bir şey
yapacağım size. Açılış yapacağım size."
Millet meraklan geliyor. Dedi ki, "Ulan"
dedi, "bu dünyada işiniz iş" dedi. Bu
dünyada işiniz iş. Doğduğunuz anda
günahkar doğuyorsunuz. günahlarınızdan
sizi arındırıyorsun.
Dinde arızalı birisi varsa aforoz edip
onu da kovalıyorum. Kralınıza tacı da
ben giydiriyorum. E günümüzde bir alt
ederseniz günahlarınızı da
affettiriveriyorum. Bu dünyada işiniz iş
öbür dünyada ne edeceksiniz la diyor.
Öbür tarafta ben yokum. Ah yuttunuz mu
deyip halkta salak ya böyle vah tüh
papacığım ne yapacağız papacığım
papacığım kurtar bizi dediklerinde durun
ben sizin papaızım diyor papa indiriyor
hop hacı papa gayrimenkulet lt şettet pt
cennetten yer satmış
bildiğin tapulu gel bakalım demiş sen
demiş çok mübarek adamsın demiş ya
cennetten girdin ya ha ş cennetin
ırmaklarından sola döndüğünde tamam
Tamam. İleride orada üç katlı içimde
Hurili, Nurili, yüzme, havuzlu,
otoparklı, Bugatti Peyron iki tane de
Ferrarili, 40 tane de hurili pı al sana
arsa harita bile çizip vurmuş satmış. E
ne neyle alıyor millet? Millet elindeki
toprağı getirdi Papay'ya verdi. Papa
bütün ipleri eline aldı. Ya
orta çarpasının ne olduğunu anladın mı?
O dinin nasıl siyasete alet edildiğini,
dinin nasıl işler yaptığını anladın mı?
Yattı mı aklınıza? Bak bunları anlatan
bir film vardı. Tamam mı? Eee Tom
Hanks'in oynadığı mesela o 13. cumaları
falan bahsediyordu. Papa onu dinden
attı. Tom Hanks'i anladın mı? O Den
Brown'un kitabı melekler, şeytanlar
falan var ya bir açın okuyun bakın bir
özlerindeki ne olduklarını, nasıl
inandıklarını bir izleyin. İlk film
izleyin görürsünüz dediğimi anlaştık. Al
Papa bütün.
Allah Allah. Papa bütün siyasi, sosyal,
hukuki bütün ekonomik gücü eline aldı.
Niye yıkılmadığını anladınız mı? Tamam.
İpler onun elinde. Ve siyasi hayatta da
feodalite diye bir şey çıktı. Tamam.
Hemen feodalite yaz altına. Tamam. De ki
temeli toprağa dayanan özünde eşitlik
ilkesinin olmadığı ekonomik bir düzendir
de. Hocam ne bu? Bunu bak federalle
karıştırma. Federal İstanbul Türklerdeki
doğu batı hayatı feodalite ne? Bu bir
abem toprak düzeni. Nasıl? Şimdi bak
şöyle şuraya yarım yamalak bir harita
çiziverim. Tamam mı? Şimdi kavimler
göçüyle millet buradan geldi mi? Geldi
değil mi? La burası Roma İmparatorluğu
muydu? Roma İmparatorluğu kabak gibi
ortadan ikiye bölündü mü? Ortada ne kral
kaldı ne imparator kaldı. Önce barbar
kavimler arkasından biz Türkler derken
tam bir kaos ortamı oluştu mu? oluştu. E
şimdi sonra şurada bir tane
baba yiğit çıktı. Tamam mı? Eline
alıverdiyle çalı odunuyla Tamam. Gelen
barbar kavimlerin kafasına ağzına yüzüne
vurdu vurdu, kovaladı gönderdi onları.
Sonrasında da çıktı o bölge halkına dedi
ki, "Lan" dedi, "bana bakın" dedi.
Gördüğünüz üzere ortada imparator yok,
kral yok. Barbar kavimler geliyordu. Ben
de onların karşısında dikildim. Burayı
kurtardım. Artık buranın a'sı, buranın
lordu, baronu, dükü, senyörü, ne bilen
nesi, soylusu, aristokrasisi benim dedi.
Artık bu topraklar benim. Siz de eğer
benim topraklarımı benim adıma
işlerseniz
ben de sizin canınızı korurum dedi. Al,
yeni bir düzen ortaya çıktı. Ağlık
dediğin böyle değişik bir düzen ortaya
çıktı. İşte onun adı ne? Feodalite
denilen bir düzen ortaya çıktı. temeli
toprak işte şurada arkasından şurada
şurada şurada şurada şurada şurada
şurada şurada şurada şurada kızamık gibi
Avrupa'nın her yerinde küçcük küçük
feodal derebeyleri ortaya çıktı. Siyasi
birlik var mı? Yok. Merkez otorite var
mı? Yok. Kim güçlüyse ayakta onun
kaldığı sistem neymiş? Feodalite
dediğiniz sistemmiş. Ne diyoruz işte
buna? Dere beylik diyoruz. Anlaştık.
feodalite derebeyliği gördüğün yerde
yorumun şu olacak. Ne diyeceksin? Siyasi
birlik yok, merkezi otorite yok.
Anlaştık. Nokta atışı sorular ve
beraberinde kültürel hayatta ise
skolastik düşünce etkili. Ne lan
skolastik? Çekomastik değil. Skolastik
ne o? Papa'ın dediği. Papa dediği
değişmez, donmuş. Tamam. Kalıplaşmış din
gerçekleri. Dogmatik düşünce dediğimiz
İncil'de düşünmek yasak. Nerede yazıyor?
Yazmıyor. E yasak. Düşünemezsin diyor.
İşte Papa kurduğu sistemde insanlar
salak olsun istiyor.
Akıllı, sorgulayan, algılayan, bilmem
neden soran adam işine gelir mi? Gelmez.
Skolastik düşünce tek kelimeyle
düşünemezsin.
Düşünemezsin. Düşünmek yasak. dogmatik
diye geçer. Donmuş, kalıplaşmış din
açıkları. Ul ilk çağdaki hellen,
Aristolar, bilmem işte şeyler tukidides,
Pisagor, Pirates hepsi ne oldu? Unutuldu
gitti. İnsanlar bir salaklaştı,
aptallaştı mı? İpler kimin elinde? İpler
Papa beyninizin elinde. Ya nokta atışı
ve sosyal hayatta da sınıflı bir ne var?
Sınıflı bir toplum yapısı var. Ne o?
Soylular, aristokratlar. Kim onlar?
toprağının büyüklüğüne göre lord, baron,
dük. Yani burada işin sırrı şu. İşin
sırrı para pul değil. Ne kadar çok
toprağın varsa, ne kadar çok toprağın
varsa o kadar soylusun, o kadar iyisin
moduna Allah nereden geldi böksürük? O
kadar iyisine geliyor. İşte bunlar da
kendi arasında lordu, barondu, düktü.
Bunların eşleri işte Lady, Barönnes,
Düşes böyle bir contest böyle gidiyor.
Anlaştık bilin. Sonra ikinci ayrıcalıklı
kısım din adamları. Ha din adamları da
her şeyi yapar ama evlenemezlerdi zaten.
İhtiyaç da yoktu. Onlar alan adam ya.
Farklı yollarla günah çıkarken o şeyleri
hallediyorlardı. Ve üçüncüsü ise
burjuva. Bak bir soylular. İki din
adamları. Aslında din adamları daha
etkin durumda.
Üçüncüsü ise burjuvalar yani
tüccarlar. Ama bunlarda bir halta
yaramıyor. Niye? Çünkü Papa kurduğu
sistemde şöyle bir olay oluşturmuş.
Kapalı
tarım ekonomisi oluşturmuş. Bu ne lan?
Kapalı tarım ekonomisi.
Yani kişiler birbirleriyle iletişime,
etkileşime geçmesin istiyor. Niye?
Papa'nın kurduğu düzen ulan her yerde
farklı. Anladın? Mesela sen bir yerin
rahibisin. Tamam mı? Mesela tamam.
İçkiye düşkünsün.
İncilin özünde içki içmek haramdır
yazıyor mu? Yazıyor. E İbranice incil
bilen var mı? Yok. Ve hemen oraya
eklemiş. Sinktus, paktus, paramelyum.
Yani bölgenin rahibi çok efkarlandığında
iki tek atabilir. Canım o kadardan bir
şey olmaz demiş. E e şimdi senin
bulunduğun coğrafyada içki içiliyor.
Normalleşmiş bu. Öbür senin öbür
taraftaki komşun o da mesela kadına kıza
düşkün olsun. E incilin özünde zina
haramdır diyor mu? Diyor. E hemen oraya
eklemiş. Canım bölgenin rahibi bir şey
olmaz canım. Dini kuvvettir. Olur olur o
kadar o kadarcık olur demiş. Ee ulan
orada içiliyor, orada bilmem ne
yapılıyor. Burada Hristiyanlık her yerde
farklı yaşanıyor. İşte Papa kapalı tarım
ekonomisini getiriyor ki bu köyden bu
köye kimse gidemesin. Buradan buraya
kimse gidemesin. Aman kurduğu düzen
nasıl ha? Ve insanlar salak gibi 1000
yıl bu karanlık çağın altında yaşadılar.
Ve o dönem burjuvat tüccar hiçbir halta
yaramıyor. Hani günümüzde zengin mengin
falan diyoruz ya işte bu. Sonra
ilerleyen süreçte Frans Stalin'de falan
bunlar yapacaklar. Niye?
Ulan o kadar çalışıyoruz, ediyoruz,
kılıyoruz bir halta hakkımız yok
diyecekler. Anlaştık. Ve köylüler bunlar
da serbest serf diye ayrılıyor. Serbest
istediği gibi gidiyor geliyor. Serfler
ise hiçbir hakkı yok. Toprak üzerindeki
ağaç gibi. Toprakla beraber al sat al
sat ver bırak. Öyle gidiyor. Anlaştık.
Al. Toplum yapısı, siyasi hayat,
kültürel hayat, sosyal hayat, feodalite,
derebeylik ne olduğunu anladın mı? Yattı
mı aklına? Şu vassal süzeren de
sorularda gelir. Tamam mı? süzeren
himaye eden demektir. Hani az önce eline
çalı odununu aldı da geldi ya. Bundan
sonra benim toprağa mekar biçerseniz
sizi korurum, himaye ederim dedi ya. Hah
o vassal da himaye edilen o köylüleri
tasvir eder. Yaprak testlerin içinde
gelir. Böyle bilin burayı al. Orta Çağ
Avrupası dediğiniz olay budur. Tamam.
Beraberinde bak burada bir formül var
sayısalcılar. Feodalite paraleldir
skolastiğe. O da zıttır merkezi
otoriteye. Yani feodalite skolastiği
gördüğün yerde merkez otorite yok.
Siyasi birlik yok diyeceksin. Peki
skolastiğin olduğu yerde bilim gelişir
mi yoksa tam tersine unutulur mu? Dünya
Papa ne dedi? Dünya düzdür dedi. Buradan
giderseniz canavarlar var yersiz dedi. E
giden de geriye gelemiyordu. Anladın?
Hala düzdür diyenler de var. Bilin. Bak
genel yapısını altaç Avrupa'nın. Bununla
alakalı sana ne verir? verir paragraf
sorusun bu kadar feodalite otorite yok
siyasi birlik yok işte böyle sorularla
gelir ve Roma ikiye bölündü Batı Roma ve
Doğu Roma diye. Doğu Roma'nın özel bir
adı vardı. Neydi Doğu Roma'nın özel adı?
Bizans
byzentium değil mi? Hangi Bizans? Evet
anladın sen. Kötü kadın Bizans değil mi?
Bak Batı Roma'nın başında Papa var. Doğu
Roma'da Patrik var. Batı Roma Katolik.
Doğu Roma Ortodoks. E bunların arasında
da var mezhepsel ayrım değil mi? Batı
Roma'da din siyaseti kontrol eder. Papa
şu yetkileriyle kralı öttürüyor. Kim
önde? Kral mı, papa mı? Papa önde. Ama
doğru ama Bizans'ta ise siyaset dini
yönetir. Anladın? Batı Roma'da Doğu
Roma'da da krallar daha etkili.
Anlaştık. Ortaçğ Avrupa'sın ilk parti
genel hatları bunlardır. Şimdi
diğerlerini de hallederelim, bitirelim
dersi. Magna Karta libertatum diye bir
şey var. Magna Karta büyük şart. 1215'te
İngiltere'de halk arıza çıkardı. Ulan
çalışıyoruz, çabalıyoruz, ediyoruz,
kılıyoruz. E hayatımız kralın, monarkın
iki dudağının arasında ben ne anladım bu
işten dediler. İsyan ettiler. Ve
İngiltere'de bir şey gerçekleşti. İlk
kez vergi ve yargı usullere bağlandı.
Artık kimse haksız yere vergi almayacak.
haksız yere yargılanıp idam edilmeyecek
dedi. Bak ta ne zaman medeniyet dediğin
İngiltere'de 1215'te verilmiş bunlar ve
kanun üstünlüğü kabul edilmeye
başlanmış. Hukuk devleti olma süreci
başlamış. Niye? Çünkü Magna Kartı
Libertuma kral imza mühür attı ya. Artık
sözleşmenin bir neyi var? Geçerliliği
var. Ve Avrupa'da kralın yetkileri ilk
kez kısıtlandı. İlk kez kı Buzer durum
bizde ne zaman? Bizde ne zaman? Bizde ı
Mahmut senedi ittifak ile bize de
palşeng etkileri ilk kez kısıtlandıydı.
Anlaştık ve Avrupa'da Magna Karta ile
beraber halk ilk kez yönetime de
katıldı. Ama bizde ne zaman? Bizde T1
meşrutiyet 1876'da
gerçekleşecek değil mi? Ve iki tane
meclis kuruldu. Ulan ellerde bir tane
meclis yokken İngiltere'de iki tane
meclis var. Ne o? Lordlar Kamerası.
Avam kamerası. Lordlar, soylular. Avam
sen ben. Halkın aşağı tabakası. İyi
magna karta yapıldı da gene akşamına
oturduk eve. E ne güzel vallahi çok
mutluyuz bugün. Vergi yargı usullere
bağlandı. Oh
oh mis gibi hukuk üstünlüğü var. Kanun
devleti hukuk süreci başladı. E
kralerini de kısıtladık. Oh ne kadar
mutluyuz. E halk yönetime de katıldı.
Ellerde bir tane meclis yok. Bizde iki
tane meclis var. Daha hala karnımız aç.
Eee haklarla karın doyuyor mu? Doymuyor
değil mi? E ne yapmak lazım?
Ne yapacağız? Gel orta kamaraya. Gel
orta kamaraya. Bize hak mak değil dayı.
Bize ne lazım? Bize torpak lazım. Torpak
değil mi? Aha yüzyıl savaşları dediğiniz
savaşlar başlayacak. İngiltere. Dünyanın
kedisi köpesi kimdir? İngiltere ile
Fransa'dır. Yüzyıl savaşları dediğiniz
olayla İngiltere Fransa'ya saldırıya
geçti. Nereye? Alsas Loren'e. Lan ne var
bu Alsas Loren'de?
Hep duyuyoruz. Abim Alsas Loren hem
alttan verir hem üstten verir. Alttan
verir. Kıymetli kömür yatakları var. Bu
dönem bir işe yaramıyor ama üstten
verir. Çok verimli toprakları var. Bizim
Çukurova'yı bildin mi? E a orayı ikiye
3'e çarp. Al sana alsasaz Loren'in
üretimi oluyor. E ne lazım? Ürün lazım,
toprak lazım, bir şey lazım değil mi?
İngilizler kaldırdı Fransa'ya savaş
zannettiler. Ta ne zaman? Ta 1337'de
başladı savaş. Ta 1453'e kadar tam 116
yıl sürdü. O yüzden bu savaşa ne
deniliyor? Yüzyıl savaş diyor. Ve bu
savaşın tarihi de tam da Osmanlı'nın
kurulduğu döneme denk geliyor mu? Tam da
Osmanlı batıda f atarken Avrupa'nın
güçlü kralı İngiltere, Fransa birbirini
yiyormuş. Bu durum
Osmanlı'nın da işine gelir mi?
Aa bir geçmedi. L öksürüğümüz Osmanlı
işine gelecek mi? Evet gelecek.
Ve bu savaşta İngilizler saldırıya
geçtiler. Resmi kaynaklarda geçer geçmez
bilinmez. Tamam mı? 1336 Temmuz sevmine
Kreasi diye bir savaş var. O savaşta
İngilizler ilk kez tarihte topu
kullanmışlar ama o top günümüz topları
gibi. Ses var, görüntü var, bir numara
yok. Ramazan topu gibi. Sıkıştırılmış
barut havada patlıyor. Ama şimdi
Fransızlar millet olarak zaten korkak
bir millettir. Fransız höt lan hıp
dediğin anda tamam mı? Arkasına bakmaz
kaçar giderler. Bu hep böyleydi. Tamam.
E o şeydir onlar. Kaypaktır onlar.
Tamam. Ve şimdi düşünsene karşında
kocaman karabit boru böyle. Ulan güm
diye bir ateş ediyor. E ses hiç duymadın
böyle bir ses. Sen duymadığın gibi
altındaki at da duymadı değil mi?
Ucundan ateş çıkıyor, duman çıkıyor. E
bilinçaltında ne var? Ateş, duman, top,
gümbürtü. Direkt bunlar kaçıyor işte
İngilizler. Abi ulan o şey karşı tarafa
bir gülle bir şey fırlatmıyor ha.
Sesinden, görüntüsünden faydalandılar.
Bu korkak Fransızları korkuttular.
Bunların hepsi kaçtı kaçtı. çekildiler.
İngilizler o toprakların üstüne
kondular. Ara ara Fransızlar deniş
yapıyorlardı ama ilerleyen süreçte tamam
mı? Fransızların içinden bir kız çıktı.
Jan Dark. Bak bunun da filmi vardır. The
Messenger falan diye. Mila Jovovi
oynuyor. Şeydeki kız. Resident Evil'daki
kız. Anladın mı? Jean Dark diye küçük
bir kız çıktı. Daha 8 10 yaşında. çıktı
geldi. Amcalar dedi ben bir Fransız
olarak bir azizeyim ben dedi. Tanrı beni
siz salak Fransızları kurtarayım diye
gönderdi. Beni lütfen kralınızla
görüştürün dedi. Kız güçcüktü ama
boyundan büyük laflar ediyordu. Kralın
huzuruna çıkardılar. Dedi ki ben kutsal
azize jandar e beni tanrısız Fransızları
korumam kurtarmam için gönderdi. Dedi ki
o İngilizlerin toplarından korkmanıza
gerek yok. dedi. Onlar sizi sadece
korkutmak amaçlı korkmaz savaşırsanız bu
savaşı siz kazanırsınız dedi. Kutsal
Aziz jandar. Tamam. Böyle geldi ordunun
başına durdu. İngilizler güm güm güm güm
topları sıktılar. Jandar hiç kıpırdamadı
bile. Sadece ses vardı değil mi? Sonra
Fransızlar da baktılar ki ulan hakikaten
de bir numara oldu yok. Biz boşuna
kaçıyormuşuz deyip ileri kata geçince
İngilizler de ulan bu salaklar nasıl
olsa kaçar deyip hazırlıksız yakalanınca
Jandark'ın ilk savaşından bunlar
Fransızlar galibiyetle ayrılmayı
başardılar. Sonraki süreçte Fransızlar
jandar kutsal Azize milli şeyleri var
yanlarında değil mi? Ve onunla beraber
saldırıya geçtiklerinde İngilizleri
söküp atmaya geriye doğru itmeye
başladılar. Sonra İngilizler baktılar ki
ulan bu jandar nereden çıktı? Bizim
bütün işin planı bozdu deyip İngilizler
de mesela şahı sahte jandlar yapıp
İngiliz ordusunun içine saldılar, haşet
ettiler onları. E ne olacak? Ne olacak?
Dediler ki bizim İngilizler olarak bu
Jandar'tan mutlak surette ne yapmamız
lazım? Kurtulmamız lazım dediler.
Jandark'ın olduğu kaleye İngilizler
saldırdılar. Jandark'ı yakaladılar. Kızı
götürdüler Londra'ya. O Times Nehrinin
olduğu o meydanların orada kızı çırp
çıplak soyup bu tekerlekli bir şeye
bağlayıp tamam mı? Kızı yuvarlaya
yuvarlaya götürüp sonra götürdüler
meydanın ortasında kızı cayır cayır
yaktılar.
Plan basitti. Fransızların jandarkı
ölürse Fransızların da şeyi gücü, inancı
biterdi değil mi? Ama Jandark'ın böyle
öldürülmesi, Fransızların içindeki bir
bir ateş bir şey yandı. Ulan Jandark'ın
öldüğü yerde biz durur muyuz be? Biz de
saldıracağız be. Biz de şey edeceğiz be
deyip tamam mı? Jandark'ın aşkıyla,
Jandark'ın intikamıyla deyip bunlar neye
geçtiler? İleri harekata geçtiler ve
Fransızlar İngilizleri ülkelerinden
söküp attılar. Alsas Lören'i geri
aldılar. Yukarıdaki paragraftan
çıkarılabilecek en kapsamlı yargı nedir?
Nedir? Nedir? Ne? AB milli manevi
duygular toptan, tüfekten, teknolojiden
üstün gelir mi? Gelir. Örnek jandar.
Bizdeki örneği Çanakkale Kurtuluş
Savaşı. Onların topu, tüfeği, tankı her
şey vardı. Bizim ise iman dolu göğsün
gibi Serhattin vardı. Anladın? Bazen
milli manevi duygular bunlara ne
gelirmiş? Ağır gelirmiş. Anlaştık. Daha
ağır basarmış. Teknolojiden daha üstün
gelirmiş. Al. Jandark hikayesi. Yüzyıl
savaşları meselesi de budur. İngiltere,
Fransa, dünyanın kendisi, köpesi
birbirlerini yediler. Ne için? Asas,
Laurin için. Genel kültür olsun hep.
Tamam. Ama sonra İngiltere'nin içinde iç
savaş çıktı. İngiltere'de bir ekip dedi
ki la oğlum dedi 116 yıldır
savaşıyorsunuz bir halt olduğu yok.
Jandar da çıktı bozulup yenilip de
geliyorsunuz. En istediği savaşmak dönün
gelin geriye. Tamam mı?
Kurtarabildiğiniz yerleri oralara dedi
bir müstakem şeyler kuralım dedi. Bunlar
dediler ki yok dedi bir ekipte olur mu
dedi? Biz sen arkada öldüreceğiz.
Hepsini hepsinin içinden geçeceğiz
dediler. Sonra Fransızlar komple
İngilizleri geriye atınca, İngilizler
yenilip gelince o ekip tamam mı? Öbürk
günler dedi ki lan biz size demedik mi
savaşm aa gideceksiniz gümbürtüye diye.
Bu sefer İngiltere'nin içinde iç savaş
çıktı. Çifte gül savaşı.
İngiliz ordusu bölündü. İki bir taraf
yakasına kırmızı gül takmış. Bir taraf
beyaz gül takmış. Al sana çifte gül
savaşıyor işte. Anladın. [kahkaha]
Nokta atışı bilgiler bilin yani. Hani
tamam mı? Bunlar hep tar öğretmen alan
sınavında falan gelecek şeylerdir.
Tamam. Hatta o İngiliz şeylerini
izlemediniz mi hepiniz Game of Thrones'u
ya kurban olduğum ya. E bunlardan da
bahseder işte. Ve beraberinde Haçlı
seferleri. Hah bura önemli. Haçlı
seferleri
haça karşı
onların haçına karşı hilalin savaşıdır.
Anlaştık. C değil o. Haça karşı hilal
yani Hristiyana karşı Müslümanın
savaşıdır. Peki sebep ne? Crusaders
Haçlarım. Sebep ne? Doğunun zenginliği,
batının sefaleti. Doğu abim o dönem o
kadar zengin, o kadar iyi, güzel, rafak,
mutluluk içinde yaşıyor ki İslam alemi.
Ama Batı papanın altında yok enterde,
yok endurjans, yok günah çıkarıyorum,
yok bilmem ne ediyorum, yok kapalı tal,
yok fe skolastik. Herifler geberip
gittilerdi yani. Hani ne istiyorlar?
Batının, Batı sefaletten kurtulup
doğunun zenginliklerine ulaşmak istiyor.
Ve bu ekonomik ama ha seferlerinin asıl
sebebi zaten nedir? Zaten ekonomiktir.
Yani anlaştık. Kudüs'ü alma isteği bu
dini, siyasi. Bak Kudüs üç ilahi, semavi
din içinde kutsal değil mi? Hristiyanlar
için kutsal. E Hazreti İsa orada doğdu.
Museviler Yahudiler için kutsal. Ağlama
duvarın şeyi orada değil mi? Süleyman
mabede orada. Müslümanlar için kutsal.
Mescid-i Aksa orada değil mi? E Kudüs
Müslümanların elindeydi. Hazreti Ömer
aldı ya.
E Kudüs'ü almak istiyor. İşte had
seferlerinin başarılı olup olmadığına
buradan bakılır. Kudüs'ü aldıysa
başarılıdır. Alamadıysa başarısızdır. 30
küsur tane falan ne olacak? Hast seferi
olacak. Tamam. Sadece biri başarılı.
Diğerlerinin hepsi başarısız olacak.
Beraberinde Papa Hristiyanlığı yaymak
istiyor. Niye? Amacı işte şey de mi?
İnsanları kurtuluyorum. Değil abim. Papa
etkisini arttırmak istiyor. Beraberinde
Kuloni tarikat diye bir tarikat var. Gaz
veriyor. Gidin gidin. Vaadedilmiş
Holand, cennetin krallığı, cennetin
toprakları gidin oralara diyor. Gidin
alın o topraklar sizindir deyip gaz
vermiş onlara. Bir de Malazgirt
savaşıyla Türkler Anadolu'ya girdik mi?
E bizler girdik Anadolu'ya değil mi?
Batıya doğru ilerliyor mu? Hem Türkleri
atalım, hem o Anadolu topraklarının
üstüne konalım, hem Kudüs'ü alalım diye.
Bunlar zomla beni bu yan tarafa. Bunlar
iç sürüsü gibi toparlanıp toparlanıp
kuzeydir. Geç yan tarafa.
Bunlar ne ettiler? Haç seferlerini
başlattılar. Birinci haç seferi. The
first Crusaders. İlk haç seferi. 600.000
kişi katıldı bu sefere. Çoluk, çocuk,
davar, doluk, emekli, dul, yetim,
bacanak. Ulan Avrupa'nın ortasında,
papanın altında ezileceğimize değil mi?
Karımı, çoluğumu, çocuğumu, anamı,
kaynanamı, babaannemi, ebemi aldım.
Yüklendik arabaya. Hadi gidiyoruz.
Nereye? Kutsal topraklara dedik. 600.000
kişi katıldı. Ama şimdi Anadolu'da
bunlarla kim mücadele etti? O dönem
Anadolu Selçuklu Devleti var, değil mi?
E, Kılıç Arslan bu 600.000 kişinin
550.000ini Anadolu'ya gömdü, halletti
onları. 50.000 tane şövalye onlar devam
ettiler ve Kudüs'ü aldılar. İşte amacına
ulaşan tek haçlı seferi 1. Ha haçlı
seferidir. Ama bu haç seferinin bir de
şeyi oldu. Urfa'da, Yafa'da bunlar
kontluklar, işte düklükler, baronluklar
falan kurdular. Ortadoğu'ya ne taşındı?
Feodalite taşındı. Hatta bunu bazı
taraçlar söylüyorumlar. Hani orta bizim
şeyde Urfa'dan Ahmet Paraş doğuda
ağırlık rejimi yok mu? Vallah kızdırmam.
Sataram köyü ha diyor ya. Ee o ağırlık
rejiminin, feodalitenin bize uyarlanmış
hali olduğunu iddia ederler. Hakikaten
de mantıklı ama yani hani bilin ve 1.
Seferi bizi olumsuz etkiledi. Niye?
Başkenti İznik'ten nereye taşıdık?
Konya'ya taşıdık. Anadolu Selçuklu
Devleti Anadolu Selçuklu Devleti
başkenti İznik'ten nereye taşıdı?
İznik'ten Konya'ya taşıdı.
Anlayabildiniz mi? He mi? Yattı mı
aklınıza? Al. Nokta atışı. 1. Haç seferi
amaçlarına ulaştılar ama 600.000 kişi
katıldılar. 550.000ini gömdük. İkinci
haçlıda Kudüs'ü de aldılar. Tamam
gittiler Kudüs'e. Amacına ulaştı.
Kudüs'ü aldılar. Orada bir Latin
Krallığı kurdular. İkinci Haçlı da
geldiler. Hem birincinin intikamını
alalım hem de daha çok gidelim o
taraflara diye. İşte Sultan Mesut onları
Eskişehir'den güneye indirmedi.
Anadolu'dan geriye püskürttük. Tamam. 3.
Aş savaşı. Bu savaş abim Avrupa'nın
önemli kralları katıldı bu savaşa. Niye?
Çünkü Selahaddin Eyyubi'yi bildiniz mi?
Selahaddin Eyyubi
Hıdin savaşıyla Selahaddin Eyyubi Kudüs
Fatih'i Kudüs'ü
Latinlerden geri almayı başardı. Aferin.
Hazreti Ömer aldıydı değil mi? İslam
dünyasında 1. Haç seferiyle Kudüs
Hristiyanların eline geçti. Latin
krallığı kurdular. Şimdi Kudüs'ü tekrar
Selahaddin Eyyub'i aldı. Bak burada bir
film önereceğim sana. Cennetin Krallığı.
The Kingdom of Heaven. İzle. Güzel
filmdir. Tamam. Ve Selahaddin Eyyubi.
Şimdi o Kudüs'e bir Selahaddin daha
lazım mı? Vallahi lazım. Tamam.
Selahaddin Eyyubi Kudüs'ü aldı. Bunun
üstüne Avrupa'nın önemli kralları 3. haş
seferine katıldılar. İngiliz, Fransız,
Alman imparatorları işte arslan yürekli
rişart. Tamam. Philip August beraberinde
Fredrik Barbarossa bunlar geldiler
katıldılar. Tamam işte bunların içinden
Fredrik Barbarossa ordusuyla Alman kralı
tamam geliyor işte Anadolu üzerinden
geçerken o Maraş göksu o taraflarda
boğulup ölüyor. Tamam mı? Ordusu
oralarda dağılmış. Onlar da oralara
yerleşmişler kalmışlar Almanlar. Hatta
I. Dünya Savaşı'nda Adolfitlerin
Rusya'ya yaptığı bir hareket var ya
Barbaros harekatı. Bu krala atıftır.
Anladın? Öbür Philip August'le Arsan
yönetli Rartla deniz yoluyla nereye
gelmişler? Oraya gelmişler. Kudüs'e
donanmalarıyla beraber gelmişler. Tamam.
Ama Araplar bunların arasına bir kızı
sokuveriyorlar. Bir Arap güzelliğ güzel
bir kızı sokuveriyorlar. Tamam. İkisi
birbirine Philip August küsüp gidiyor.
Fransız kralı sap gibi kim kalıyor?
Arsan Richard. O da esir düşüyor falan
falan derken Kudüs kimde kaldı?
Müslümanlarda kaldı. Soru Avrupa
krallarının katıldığı sefer hangisidir?
Taretmenlerin alan sınavında size sordu.
Sonra süreç devam etti. 1204'te 4. Haç
savaşı. Daha bundan sonra da var da bu
4dü anlatılır. Bu savaş bu harçlı seferi
sapık harçlı seferi diye geçer. Niye?
Şundan dolayı abim papa orduları
gönderiyor gönderiyor. Ulan bunlar
yenilip yenilip geliyor mu? Bu başarısız
olup bozulup bozulup geliyor mu?
Geliyor. Tamam mı? Papa diyor ki ulan
ben bunları deniz diyor karadan
göndermeyeyim. Ben bunları diyor
denizden gönderim galiba diyor bu Bizans
bir pislik yapıyor, çamur yapıyor, bir
şey yapıyor falan diyor. Tamam bunları
İtalya'dan, Roma'dan bindiriyor,
gemilere gönderiyor Kudüs'e doğru derken
yolda bir haber geliyor. Tamam. Bu eee
Bizans'a imparator olmak isteyen bir
adam. Bunlara diyor ki haçlılara y diyor
gelin diyor. Nereye gidiyoruz? E biz
haçlıyız ulan diyor. Nereye gideceğiz?
Kudüs'e gidiyoruz diyor. Durun diyor ya
önce gelin bir İstanbul'a tamam. Bir
Konstantini'ye bir gelin. Bana yardım
edin. Beni bir kral edin diyor. Ben de
size diyor toprak da veririm, bir şey de
veririm diyor. Tamam. Bunun üstüne bizim
haçlılar. Ulan Kudüs'ü ne edeceğiz?
Hazır orada bedava toprak var mı? Var
deyip adamlar saptılar amacından nereye
gittiler? İstanbul'a gittiler. İşte sapı
karşılığından kastımız bu. Amacından
saptı. Amacından herifler Kudüs'e
gidiyoruz diye nereye geldiler?
İstanbul'a geldiler. Doğu Roma'ya,
Bizans'a geldiler. Orayı yakıp yıkıp
yağmaladılar. İşte bu durum haçlı
savaşlarının dini değil de ekonomik
olduğunun en büyük göstergesidir. İşte
bunu sorarlar size. Anlaştık. Ve o arada
da Katolikler, gelenler, Harçlılar
Katolikti. İstanbul'dakiner Ortodokstu.
İşte Katolik, Ortodoks ayrımı da burada
belirginleşti. Nasıl İslam dünyasında
Kerbela olayı, Hristiyan dünyasında da
4. Haç savaşıyla tamamı bu mezhepler,
Katolik, Ortodoks, Şii, Sünni
birbirleriyle iyice koptu gittiler.
Anlaştık. Al. Hat savaşları meselesi
budur. Yani İstanbul'u Fatih'ten önce o
latinler kendileri almışlar. Anlaştık.
Bilin ve beraberinde Haç Savaşı'nın
sonuçları, feodalite dediğiniz olay, o
ağırlık rejimi Ortadoğu'ya taşındı mı?
Taşındı. Urfa'da, Yafa'da kontluklar
falan kuruldu mu? Kuruldu. Hatta bizim
doğudaki ağlığın evrime uğramış hali
midir? Evet diyebiliriz. Beraberinde
Akdeniz ticareti canlandı. Niye? Sürekli
harçlılar geliyor gidiyor, geliyor
gidiyor. Hiçbir şey yapmayıp bir tane
tekneye balık ekmek versen o bileş
askeri malzeme satsan vallahi köşeyi
dönersin. Anladın? Bilin. Beraberinde
Türklerin batıan ilerleşi yavaşladı.
Niye? E şimdi bu harçlarla uğraşıyoruz
derken e Türkler arada tampon bölge
Anadolu'da biziz. Başkentimizi İznik'ten
nereye taşıdık mesela? Konya'ya taşıdık.
Anladın? Beylikler mücadele etti. Mesela
kim yok? Sadece Çakaby hariç. Diğer
beylikler mücadele etti. Anadolu
Selçuklu mücadele etti mesela. Ama
batıyla eşimiz yavaşladı ve beraberinde.
Kudüs kurban olduğum Müslümanlarda kaldı
mı? E kaldı. Tamam. Nokta atışı. Bir de
bu coğraf şeyin eee haç seferlerinin
tamam mı? Bilimsel kültürel sonuçları da
var. Mesela ne o şimdi? Barut, pusula,
kağıt mürekkep, matba. Bunlar kimin
icadı? Bunlar Çin'in icadıydı. Değil mi?
Çin'in icadıydı. E şimdi bunları eee
Çinlilerden biz Türkler öğrendik. E
Müslüman olunca Araplara öğrettik. E
Haçlı savaşlarıyla da Araplardan kim
aldı? İngilizler şeyler Avrupalılar
aldı. Avrupalılar barutu aldılar. Barutu
aldılar. götürdüler. Barutu ateşli
silahlarda kullanıp feodaliteye son
verdiler. Merkezi krallar güçlendi.
Merkezi krallar güçlendi. Feodalite sona
erdi. Avrupa'nın siyasi yapısı değişti
mi? Değişti. Sonra pusulayı öğrenen
Avrupalılar gemilere atlayıp coğrafi
keşifleri yaptılar. Avrupa'nın ekonomi
hayatı değişti mi? Değişti. Sonra kağıt
mürekkep matba ile önce İtalya'da
Rönesansı. Bak bunlar da yeni çağ
tarihin konuları. İşte bunları da şeyin
içinde yedirdim, anlattım size. Tamam.
Rönesansla ilim İtalya'da başlayıp ilim,
bilim, film kültür teknik alanında
ilerlediler mi? Dört ninja kaplumbaştı.
Leonardo Donat Rafael Michelangelo onlar
ve reform ile de Martin Luther'in
önderliğinde din alanında gittiler mi?
Gittiler. Ulan ne aç savaşlarıymış.
Avrupa'nın siyasi, ekonomik reformunu
yani kültürel, düşünsel hayatını
ilerleyen süreçte değiştirdiler mi?
Değiştirdiler. Al. Avrupa tarihi, Orta
Çağda Avrupa genel hatlarıyla. Gel orta
kameraya. Genel hatlarıyla budur.
Kıymetli kardeşlerim hepinizi seviyorum.
Haydi bakalım sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere. Haydi bakalım.